the message for today
is how are you doing very simple
how are you doing and i emphasize
the you how are you doing and he opened
his mouth and taught them saying
blessed are the poor in spirit for
theirs is the kingdom of heaven
blessed are they that mourn for they
shall be comforted
blessed are the meek for they shall
inherit the earth
blessed are they which do hunger and
thirst after righteousness
for they shall be filled blessed are the
merciful
for they shall obtain mercy blessed are
the pure
in heart for they shall see god
blessed are the peacemakers for they
shall be called the children of god
blessed are they which are persecuted
for righteousness sake
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven
blessed are ye
when men shall revile you and persecute
you
and shall say all manner of evil against
you falsely
for my sake be glad for
so persecuted they're the prophets which
were before you
ye are the salt of the earth but if the
salt
have lost his savor wherewith shall it
be salted
it is then forth good for nothing but to
be cast out
and to be trodden underfoot of men ye
are the light of the world
a city that is set on an hill cannot be
hid
neither do men like to candle and put it
under a bushel
but on a candle stick and it giveth
light unto all that are in the house
let your light so shine before men that
they may see your good works
and glorify your father which is in
heaven
wherever you are watching us we welcome
you
we thank you for your interest in god's
word for your love for truth
and may the lord bless you as you listen
to these words which i believe
god has given me to give to you i am
always delighted
to welcome anyone listening who is not a
seventh-day adventist
wherever you are thank you again and may
the lord
bless you so much that you will want to
come
and fellowship with us again whether via
this medium
or by attending one of our churches in
your local area
i welcome all the little children who
may be watching
children understand much more than what
we give them credit for
so if the little boys and girls watching
thank you very much jesus at the age of
understood the truth of the bible josiah
at the age of eight he was the king
of judah and he did what was right in
the sight of god
there was a little boy who provided fish
and bread which jesus used to feed five
thousand
so if the little children watching thank
you very much for loving jesus
and may god bless you through this
message i hope i make it so simple
that you will understand the message for
today
is how are you doing very simple
how are you doing and i emphasize
the you how are you doing
before i get into that let me ask you to
do three little things for me
favor number one wherever you are
preserve
reverence because god is holy under all
circumstances
and in all settings so wherever you are
preserve an atmosphere
of reverence and god will be pleased
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth this
is based on jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
which says then the lord put forth his
hand
and touched my mouth and the lord said
unto me behold
i have put my words in thy mouth
and i really and truly want god to put
his words in my mouth
why is that because jesus tells us in
john
6 63 the words that i
speak unto you they are spirit and they
are life the words of god
are living words the words created the
universe
the word raised the dead and so i want
to speak
god's words because my opinions have no
saving value favor number three i want
you to
think as you listen isaiah 1 18
come now let us reason together seth the
lord
think as you listen it is very
encouraging to me and perhaps to you
to know that we serve a reasonable god
it is a reasonable god who will invite
us to
reason with him it also means that god
comes down
and speaks our language and listens to
us and so the bible says come now let us
reason together seth the lord and i hope
you will
accept that invitation from god let's
bow our heads now
and pray father in heaven touch my mind
touch my mouth touch me completely
not for my sake de god but for the sake
of your glory
for the sake of the beloved audience
whom you love so much
if i've offended you forgive me cleanse
my heart dear god
and my mind may i be a clean instrument
in your hand
grant me simple language father that
those listening may
understand the message you have prepared
for them
if anyone listening to my words father
has contracted the coronavirus
i ask in the name of jesus the great
physician
healed that person 100 percent their god
not slightly or barely i as humbly
heal that person or those persons
100 and let that healing
creating that person a love for you dear
god
i pray for anyone else who's speaking
right now put your words
in that person's mouth i pray now i
commit this service to your glory
give us the blessing because we need it
i pray in jesus name
amen last night
i did some tossing and turning as i
wrestled with god
on the question what should i tell his
people
now and some ideas came across my head
i thought well perhaps i could talk
about the beast
and he's perhaps receives too much
attention than he deserves
i thought maybe i can talk about the ten
plagues or talk about
the ten commandments or talk about some
aspect of revelation as it relates to
daniel
but i only received peace of mind
when i finally decided i will talk to
you
personally do not view this as a sermon
even though it is i want you wherever
you are to
understand that i am speaking to you
not necessarily to the person next to
you now the person next to you should
understand
i am speaking to him or her but i want
you to understand
i am speaking directly to you
as an individual and our subject is
how are you doing we're living in a
tumultuous world my listening friend
how are you doing multiple
thousands of jobs have been lost because
of the lockdown
imposed upon society by covid19
have you lost your job how are you doing
schools have been closed children have
to stay at home
complicating lives for working parents
they now have to make arrangements
to have the children supervised i ask
you
how are you doing because
many have lost their jobs many are
facing
foreclosure on their homes and when i
say many
i mean millions and so i ask again
how are you doing as you sit
stand lie or listen to my voice there
is a god for whom
nothing is impossible when god told
abraham
he would have a son in genesis 17 verse
the bible says then abraham fell on his
face and laughed
because it sounded impossible to him
because he was now about a hundred years
old
in genesis 18 when god told abraham
again that sarah
would bear a child for him the bible
says sarah
laughed and so we have man and wife
laughing at god because what god said
made no sense to them in the human mind
with their limited finite restricted
human thinking
and so they're left now if i were to say
to you
that given the employment climate of
this country because of covet 19
that god can find you a job you may
laugh
if i were to say to you that you're
facing foreclosure and god can work a
miracle
to put that off you may laugh because in
your mind
it is impossible but the bible says for
god
nothing is impossible when sarah laughed
god told
abraham in genesis 18 14
is anything too hard for the lord
it's a question that does not did not
require an answer from abraham
the answer was so obvious and god is
asking you today right now my sister
my brother is anything too hard for the
lord
you have to answer that and i'm sure
your answer will be
no god nothing is too hard for god
in luke 18 verse 27 jesus told the
disciples
the things which are impossible with men
are possible with god
i'll say that again listen
microscopically listen closely
concentrate
the things which are impossible with men
or people are possible with god
what your s state or your town
or your township or your county cannot
do for you god can do
if he so desires the things which are
impossible with men
are possible with god can you believe
that
in the circumstances that you're
currently facing
84 11 no good thing will he withhold
from them that walk uprightly can you
believe
that whatever is good for you god will
provide
and so i ask you again how
are you doing right now where you are
before i go any further let me pray
again father in heaven
as i speak to those whom you love
passionately
give me the right words i pray in jesus
name amen
to get into the heart and soul of how
are you doing
let's look at a quality god has given to
us
in genesis 1 we read verse 26
and god said let us make man in our
image
after our likeness let us
make man in our image
after our likeness this did not only
apply
to the character man was supposed to
develop
god's image was to be seen not only in
character
it was also to be seen in physical
appearance it was to be seen
in everything that humanity did prior to
sin of course
of course god still has that requirement
now because he never changes his
standards
god's character his image his glory
his likeness was intended to be
reflected in
everything the human race did the
marriage union
is a reflection of the image of god the
headship of the man
is a reflection of the image of god all
of this
was god's design that he would be
reflected when he
said let us make man in our image
now there is a quality of god that he
has given to us
it is a quality let me use the word it
is a power
that god has given us and that power
is the power of individuality
you are separate from
and different from every other human
being on the face of the earth i say
that again
i'll say differently god does not
clone god is a god of
individuality and uniqueness no
two people are alike this is a quality
and a power god has given to us the
power of
individuality and the power to make
individual choices
and individual decisions and i must
trust this
in this quality of this power of
individuality
because it is essential as i move into
the heart and soul of
how are you doing
when god made adam and eve
he did not make them together he made
them on the same day
but did not make them together
genesis chapter 2 verse 7 the bible says
and the lord god formed man of the dust
of the ground
and breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life
and man became a living soul that verse
refers to adam only not eve
eve was made in verse 21 and verse 22
and the lord god caused a deep sleep to
fall upon adam
and he slept and he took one of his ribs
and closed up the flesh instead thereof
and the rib which the lord god had taken
from man
made he a woman and brought her unto the
man
adam and eve were made at different
times
on the sixth day of creation god
could have made them at the same time
why not one of the reasons is god made
them
as individuals they had to make
decisions
individually to serve him they had to
decide
individually to obey god
god made individuals it is something i
love to stress
because very often people will not
follow god
they hear the truth they are convicted
by the truth
but will not accept it because of what
someone else might do
or say or how that person might react we
do not understand
that god requires of us that we make
individual decisions to serve him
and to obey him and to walk in the steps
of his son jesus christ
and so god made adam by himself
god made eve by herself yes
we have responsibilities one towards
another i can influence you
and you can influence me yes this is
part of
living together but at the very
foundation of the society
that god set up were individuals
individuality now having said that
let's assume that you're listening to
this program and you're surrounded by
people
your wife your children your friends
while you may be surrounded by people
god is looking at you
and he's watching how you are relating
to the words you're hearing
what decision will you make when i
arrive at the point of making an appeal
how is your heart responding to the
words you're hearing
god is focusing on you
steps of christ page 100 paragraph one
the relations between god and each soul
are as distinct and
full as though they were not another
soul upon the earth
to share his watch care in the parable
of the lost sheep
in luke 15 the bible says from verse 3
and 4
what manner of you having 100 sheep
if he lose one of them
doth not leave the 1909 in the
wilderness
and go after that which was lost until
he find it that parable teaches us
several things
it teaches us that christ came to save
the only
world in the vast universe that went
astray
the parable teaches us that if only one
person on earth had gone astray
jesus christ would have come the parable
teaches us
the importance god places on individual
responsibility
and the value the individual has to god
and so i am saying again you may be
listening to this presentation
surrounded by others but god is looking
at you when god spoke the ten
commandments
from mount sinai and it was jesus christ
speaking for his father
he said thou shalt have no other gods
before me
thou is singular
thou shalt not make unto thee any given
image that
is singular
when god came down to investigate the
catastrophe in the garden of eden
he said to adam adam where at thou he
did not say adam and eve where are ye
that's plural where at thou he came to
adam
individually then he came to eve
individually
then he spoke to the serpent
individually when he handed out
punishment he spoke to eve individually
he spoke to adam
individually this is not to discount
the group because god brought the first
group together
adam and eve god formed the first couple
what i'm stressing
as i try to address what concerns you
may have
is god forgetting me is god blessing
others
has god passed me by the answer is no
because god begins with the individual
and you may be the only one in your town
who believes
that god does not care but he cares for
you god
focuses on individuals in the book
a mind character and personality volume
2 page 4 23
paragraph 2. i'll give that reference
again mind
character and personality volume 2.
page 4 23 paragraph 2 the servant of the
lord writes
the gospel deals with individuals
i pause before i give you examples of
individuals
touched by the gospel the gospel deals
with individuals
in hebrews chapter 1 verse 3
the bible says who being the brightness
of his glory
and the express image of his person and
upholding all things by the word of his
power
when he had by himself
purged our sins sat down on the right
hand of the majesty on high
when he had by himself why
was he by himself the father had
temporarily
turned away jesus knew that and he cried
my god
my god why hast thou forsaken me mark 14
the disciples forsook him and fled
christ was
all by himself he had to make an
individual choice
to stay on that cross he had to make
an individual choice in the garden of
gethsemane
to go through that terrible suffering
yes the angel gabriel came down
and strengthened him luke 22 43
but christ had to make the decision
himself
god his gospel
is about individuals first and so the
quotation
mind character and personality volume
two page four
twenty three paragraph two says the
gospel deals with individuals
every human being has a soul to save
or to lose each has an individuality
separate and distinct from all others
each must be convicted for himself
converted for himself
each must receive the truth repent
believe
obey for himself he must exercise his
own will
he no one can do this work by proxy no
one can believe for you no one can
repent for you
this is an individual work yes there
were times
when the nation of israel repented all
that meant was
individuals repented
my question for you again how are you
doing
there are seven billion plus people on
the face of the earth
god is looking at you
there are seven billion police plus
people
on the face of the earth there are
millions unemployed
and god is noticing your situation
you're all alone with four children your
husband left you
you're tearing your hair out trying to
figure out how will i provide for my
children
god is looking at your situation
and god is saying to you i can help
when the father brought his epileptic
boy to the disciples to be healed they
could not heal him
the account is in mark chapter 9.
christ came off the mountain of
transfiguration there was a brouhaha
a commotion and christ asked what's
going on and he was informed by the
father
i brought my son and your disciples
could not heal him
in verse 21 jesus asked the father how
long is it to go
since this came upon him and he said of
a child
and often times mark 9 23 22 he hath
cast him into the fire
and into the waters to destroy him but
if thou canst do anything have
compassion upon us
and help us now this is the father
speaking
an individual jesus said if thou canst
believe
all things are possible to them that
and straightway the father of jesus
cried out and said with tears
lord i believe help thou my unbelief
i believe this is a man i
believe but all the faith he had was
this
you know god is a good god we say that
all the time psalm 105
for the lord is good and this is
absolutely true god is good
but we ought sometimes to pause and
reflect meditate
focus on the extent to which god is good
the bible says without faith
it is impossible to please god hebrews
11 6
that man virtually said this is all the
faith i had
because he said lord i believe help thou
my unbelief he says i believe that he
says unbelief
his faith was small here is an
individual
with little faith
but all the faith he had he put in
christ
and jesus answered his cry granted him
his petition and
healed his son help thou my unbelief
wherever you are if this is all the
faith
you have put it in christ
exercise that faith and with that
exercise of faith
say as that man said lord help thou my
unbelief and anyone who utters that cry
will not go unrewarded by god of mercy
who is listening and watching my
question to you which is the title of
the message
how are you doing
let's go to john chapter 5.
john 5 we'll read from verse 1.
i read from the king james version of
the bible it's my favorite version
but when i study i refer to other
versions but for public
speaking and memorization i just love
the music
and the language of the king james
version before i read that passage
let's pray again dear god hold me
in your arms uphold me with your power
let my voice be your voice my words your
words i pray
in jesus name amen
after this there was a feast of the jews
and jesus went up to jerusalem now there
is at jerusalem by the sheep market a
pool
which is called in the hebrew tongue
bethesda having five porches
in these lay a great multitude of
impotent fork of blind
halt withered waiting for the moving of
the water
for an angel went down at a certain
season into the pool and troubled the
water whosoever then first
after the troubling of the water stepped
in was made whole of whatsoever disease
he had
and a certain man was there notice the
bible says
there was a great multitude of blind
halt withered
waiting for the moving of the water a
great multitude
now the focus is on one the individual
and a certain man was there verse five
which had an infirmity
thirty and eight years he had been
unemployed
a long time he had been sick a long time
he had been searching whatever
a long time this man had been suffering
and there's someone
listening to me who has been in an
unfortunate condition
for years fighting cigarettes for years
cycling alcohol
for years fighting drug addiction this
man had a condition
38 years
verse 6 when jesus saw him lie
and knew that he'd been now a long time
in that case
he said unto him will thou be made whole
there were sick people all around jesus
remember the bible says in these laid
the porches a great
multitude of impotent fork of blind halt
withered a great multitude jesus
zeroed in for reasons best known to him
on
one man
will vow be made whole
let me put that in fresno english would
you like your circumstances changed
would you like a reversal of fortune
fortune is not the best word but i'll
use it
would you like your life to take a
different direction
would you like your marriage improved
would you like to see a difference in
the behavior of your children
jesus targets the man's conditions wilt
thou be made whole
the impotent man answered him verse 7
sir i have no man
when the water is troubled to put me
into the pool
but while i'm coming another step is
down before me
at the question of jesus will thou be
made whole he should have just said yes
but god is so merciful so patient
jesus listens his excuse sir
i have no man
the word or the expression i have no man
simply means
i have no person whether male or female
to help me someone
listening to me now you've come to the
place where you believe
not no friends or relatives are willing
to help you
you have no man no woman
no human being no created being who can
come to your rescue
and you're up to here in trouble and
distress
and there's no one to whom you can turn
and the god of the universe is looking
right at you
and via this message and by his spirit
he has come to where you are
and as jesus asked that man
will thou be made whole when blind
bartimaeus cried out thou son of david
have mercy upon me jesus said what will
thou
have me to do unto thee what do you want
when god puts that question to you god
is giving you a blank check and he tells
you write the amount i've already signed
it in the blood of my son
you write the amount here is a blind
check a blank check
what do you want
and christ said to that man will thou be
made whole
do you want your sins forgiven you need
a job
are you sick you need healing
tell god what you need
regardless of who else is around you
suffering tell
god what you need we read verse 6 again
he said unto him will thou be made whole
the impotent man answered him sir
i have no man when the water is troubled
to put me into the pool
there are some people whose condition
make them close to helpless i say close
to helpless because as long as god is on
the throne
no one is entirely helpless but from the
standpoint of human assistance they are
helpless
i have no man when the water is troubled
to put me into the pool
but while i am coming as i make my
feeble effort
because i am so slow i cannot walk so i
have to try to roll my way into the pool
sick people who can walk they get in
before me another step is down before me
people are always getting ahead i
submitted my application
along with others they got a call for an
interview i did not get one
i submitted my application for medical
school my friend was called
i was not called i did this i did that
along with others
they receive responses i receive none
while i am coming
another step is down before me there's
always someone ahead of me in this life
jesus says unto him arise
take up thy bed and walk
he did not say that to any other sick
person
gathered around that pool insofar as the
bible informs us
or the writings of ellen white why
christ knows why or whatever christ does
is right whatever god does is right the
lord is righteous in all his ways
and holy in all his works psalm 145 17
for reasons best known to christ christ
did not
heal anyone else but that man
arise take up thy bed
and walk that was the man's
need to walk and
immediately the man was made whole
and took up his bed and walked and on
the same day
was the sabbath
the pharisees said unto him that was
cured it is the sabbath day
it is not lawful for thee to carry thy
bed he answered them
he that made me whole the same said unto
me take up thy bed and walk
then as they him what man is that which
said unto thee
take up thy bed and walk and he that was
healed was not who it was
for jesus had conveyed himself away a
multitude being in that place
here we have repeated that there was a
multitude both sick and those not sick
afterward jesus findeth him in the
temple verse 14
and said unto him behold thou art made
whole
sin no more lest the worst thing
come unto thee let me introduce a
concept into this presentation
it is frequently not welcome but it's
necessary
jesus told that man
sin no more lest a worse
thing come unto thee in making that
statement
christ connected sin with sickness
someone's saying well i haven't done
anything wrong and i'm sick it may not
be the result of your individual sin
it may simply be that you live in a
world of sin let me say it again
sickness is the result of sin
suffering is the result of sin christ
suffered
he never sinned but he carried our sins
sickness
is the result of sin suffering is the
result of sin
jesus told that man sin no more lest the
worst thing come unto thee
in chapter 8 of the book of john when
jesus forgave
the woman taken in adultery she said go
and sin no more
at the foundation of all suffering and
sickness
and misery is this thing called sin
why am i saying that i'm saying that to
introduce
this concept to you as you listen to
this message
how are you doing before i introduce the
concept let me pray
father in heaven as i continue on the
downslope of the message
continue to give me your words and your
thoughts i pray
in jesus name amen in trying to deal
with any
crisis in your life whether it's job
loss
sickness family crisis nothing going
right
the first question you should ask
is this something between me and my god
of course if someone listening is is uh
not a believer
not an is an atheist perhaps the person
may not feel the need to ask that
question
but whether you're an atheist or not
there's a god in heaven
and i'm suggesting to you the first
question to
ask is this something between
me and my god or have i
offended god what have i done that
possibly brought on these calamities
upon me
these unfortunate circumstances into my
life david prayed
in psalm 139 verse 23 24
search me your god and know my heart
try me and know my thoughts and see if
there be
any wicked way in me and lead me in the
way everlasting i say again
the foundation the source of sickness
suffering calamity unfortunate
circumstances
sin is a result of all of that and as i
continue with how are you doing
i want to introduce to you the very very
real concept of
examining your relationship with god
first
not the economy not the health system
not whether you should wear or not wear
a mask
have i done something to offend my god
sin lights are the foundation
of all suffering i sometimes say it may
sound
silly it's not silly it's very serious
people don't die
of cancer they die
because of sin you go back to genesis
chapter 2 read verse 16 17
listen to what the bible says and the
lord god commanded the man saying
of every tree of the garden thou mayest
freely eat
but of the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil thou shalt not eat of it for in
the day thou eatest thereof thou
shall surely die listen to the words of
god in the day thou eatest thereof
thou shall surely die god pronounce
one penalty for sin and that was
death he did not say thou shalt be sick
he did not say there shall be floods and
famine and drought
and disease and landslides and mudslides
and typhoons
and hurricanes and snowstorms all god
said was
thou shalt surely die
all the catastrophes that flow or that
beset humanity today
are all expressions of thou shalt
surely die we know in genesis chapter 3
that god said to adam
because thou has hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife
and has eaten of the tree of which i
commanded thee saying
thou shalt not eat of it curse is the
ground for thy sake
genesis 3 17 the ground was cursed
because of sin
god didn't tell adam if the day thou
eatest thereof i will curse the ground
he didn't say that
he simply said thou shalt surely die but
a curse condition
is an expression of a dying society
verse 16 genesis 3 unto the woman he
said
i will greatly multiply thy sorrow and
thy conception
in sorrow thou shalt bring forth
children
not only painfully but when you see the
lives the children lead
sorrow will break your heart this is an
expression
of a dying world god only said thou
shalt surely die
but we have all these conditions that
beset humanity
because the foundation is sin
how are you doing what is the
relationship between you
and your god is this something
in your life that displeases god
as i said earlier when adam and eve
sinned
god came down and spoke to adam
individually
god spoke to eve god spoke to the
serpent he announced punishment to eve
he announced punishment to adam as a
matter of fact in genesis 22 to 24
god tossed the man out of the garden
of course the woman went with him but he
tossed the man
individual why did god curse the earth
because
the man had seen individual
how are you doing
are you suffering are you sick
there is a god in heaven
who is willing wanting and waiting
to transform your circumstances
give your life to him now i'm not saying
if you do not give your life to god
he cuts off immediately i'm not saying
that because jesus in his mercy
he tells us in matthew 5 verse 44
that ye may be the children of your
father which is in heaven
in verse 43 for verse 45 sorry for he
maketh the sun to rise
on the evil and on the good and sendeth
rain on the just and on the unjust
so god is so good the sun which
represent
life is given to the evil and to the
good the rain which represents life
is given to the just and the unjust so
even though you may be unjust and
evil and i'm sure you're not that but
even though you are
god still exercises mercy
but god wants to do much more for you
because god has blessings that are
special
his choices blessings and he reserves
them
for those who obey him
and so i ask you again how are you doing
have you lost your job have you
contracted the coronavirus
are you terribly sick has the doctor
giving you bad news
have your children gone straight into
the world
is your spouse making your life a living
hell
how are you doing there
is a god who is speaking to you
individually his name is jesus
here's what he tells you in matthew 11
verse 28 come
unto me not to a church
not at first but i need to say quickly
he has a church
when you come to him he will guide you
to that church
but he says first come unto me
god is not a concept god is not a vapor
christ is a living person he is divine
he is human even as i talk about jesus
he's watching me listening to me he has
still his human condition
he understands it is someone who
understands your condition
and can do something about it in his
divinity he understands in his humanity
and he says to you come unto me
all ye that labor and are heavy laden
i will give you rest
our subject how are you doing this
invitation
is no different really from what christ
said to the man at the pool of bethesda
will thou be made whole in matthew 11 28
come unto me all you that labor
and the heavy lane christ is saying
would you like your burden
lightened or removed would you like me
to carry it for you
you have to say individually yes
and jesus says come
let's see how open-minded jesus is and
broad-minded
as we continue how are you doing listen
to the words closely
come unto me all ye that labor
and are heavy laden i will give you rest
what does it mean by all ye that labor
males females
white black hispanic
or latino or latina native american
european asian educated
uneducated rich
poor despised beloved
employed unemployed jesus says
come but god's invitation is individual
and so he's saying to you come
let's talk about your unemployment come
let's talk about your sickness come we
will talk about it
i will do something about it come unto
me
all ye that labor and the heavy laden i
will give you rest now when jesus says
i will give you rest you need to
understand
that jesus says of himself in john 14
verse 6
i am the way the truth
christ cannot lie titus chapter 1 verse
which god that cannot lie promised god
cannot lie god does not lie and jesus
christ is just like god
christ does not lie and he says come to
me come
you may be listening to me seated in a
wheelchair and i speak with great
respect
you don't have to move you come to god
here
and here and jesus says come to me
all you that labor and a heavy laden
i will give you rest
take my yoke upon you and learn of me
for i am meek and lowly in heart and ye
shall find
rest unto your souls my yoke is easy
my burden is light following
christ is taking on a light
burden let me say that again following
christ
is the act of taking on a light burden
and we give him our burden when christ
came by where john the baptist was
baptizing
in john 1 29 john the baptist said to
the listening crowd
behold the lamb of god which taketh away
the sins of the world
the word taketh away simply means to
carry as to carry a load
he bears it away when i travel
in airports or going through airports
i always smile when i see a man in a
suit with a backpack
just doesn't seem right to me a man in a
suit and with a backpack
backpacks are ubiquitous you see them
everywhere people carry these backpacks
jesus carries the backpack of our
burdens
and so john said behold the lamb of god
that carries the burdens of the world
and the greatest burden you can carry
if we listen to the words of christ come
on to me only that labor
and a heavy laden and i will give you
rest the greatest
burden you and i can carry is the burden
of sin as i told you earlier
all god said was in the day thou eat his
thereof thou shalt surely die
but we have all these calamities
sickness suffering floods disease
whatever else
all these things are expressions of a
dying world
then if we come to god the number one
thing we need is the removal of the
burden of sin
because with the departure of sin goes
several although several burdens and
calamities
as long as we live in this earth we will
have troubles and trials yes
god allows some for our the testing of
our faith
but someone walking hand in hand with
god
will not experience the same troubles as
someone who does not walk with god
if that were the case where is the
advantage of walking with god
yes god's people have troubles yes
they'll have trials
yes they'll have tribulations but they
will be managed by god
now let me tell you something about god
it's a psychological principle but the
true principles of psychology are in the
bible
if your burden is to carry this
and god sees it is necessary for the
perfection of your character
that you carry this burden god will
change the way you
see the burden he
changes the mind for example here am i
walking across a plane and i come across
a mountain i have to get over that
mountain to continue my journey
i'm depressed i'm discouraged i'm sad
i'm frustrated hey this mountain is
getting on my nerves here comes a
mountain climber who's also walking
and he sees the mountain
and his response his reaction is
different
he breaks into a smile because as a
mountain climber
he sees a mountain as an exciting
challenge and he just can't wait to
determine which face of the mountain he
will use
to climb to reach the summit while i not
a mountain climber
i'm depressed and i'm sitting down in my
tears wishing the mountain would vanish
god changes our minds
and so we may see our circumstances
different
whether he changes the mind or he
changes the circumstances
or he changes both
because god knows what's best for us god
is willing
as i said waiting wanting to ameliorate
improve your circumstances
and as i come to the end of the message
i appeal to you from my heart
as someone who has to lean on god
someone who needs the divine working
in my life day by day moment
by moment it is not
necessary to remain in your misery
it is not necessary at all because
there's a god
you see misery does not come from god
suffering
is not of god god is a god of blessing
suffering is a result of sin
it is not necessary for someone to
remain
in his or suffering there is a god who
is willing to change your circumstances
and all i'm saying to you is
in the presence of god and by the power
of his word
come to god you may say but i'm a
christian
re-commit your life to god
consider this concept in the bible
death is represented by asleep
which means last night you and i were
dead
in a certain sense we were dead to the
world
we knew not what was happening someone
could have come into the bedroom or
wherever we slept
slit our throats stolen our money stolen
our cell phones we had no clue we were
asleep
we were dead symbolically sleep is death
then when we wake in the morning
we can see that as a new life
a brand new life a resurrection is a new
day
in that sense every day is a brief
little lifetime
it ends with death then god by his mercy
gives us another lifetime which is a day
today is a new lifetime for you it is
brief i'm saying to you today
give your life to god
last night all over the world
including where you are people went to
sleep
and i say this often they were found
dead this morning
every morning people found dead in
hospitals
on the streets in homeless shelters in
private homes
on the battlefield every morning
around the world people who go to bed
the night before
are found dead now
you and i went to bed last night we're
alive today what am i trying to say
god has chosen to preserve our lives
another day
and i'm saying to you this may be the
day when god is saying my son my
daughter
come give your life to me put your life
in my hand
because anything in my hand i can defend
i can sustain
i can nourish i can protect
give him your life our subject was
how are you doing right now
as i close this message talk to god
tell god i need a job
someone wrote me on uh what's it what's
that last night i believe it was
i am through with all this god stuff
this christianity stuff
i am a defeated man i wrote back quickly
why god doesn't answer my prayer i have
weakness
this weakness that weakness i fall i
fall i cannot stop so i wrote him in
some bible verses
and a chapter from steps to christ he
wrote back this morning with a sample of
what he read
he said i found this very encouraging
and i sent him an audio recording and he
wrote back thank you very much this was
encouraging
and i'm praying for him and i want him
to know there's a god
who can pull him from the brink
wherever you are give this to god
there's one good reason you must give
this to god this is your life your heart
because it belongs to him he is creator
and his savior the bible says in first
corinthians 6
20 for year bought with a price the
bible says in psalm 24 verse 1
the earth is the lord's and the fullness
thereof the world and they that dwell
therein
you belong to god and so in giving your
life to god
you're just giving him what is his tell
god you need a job
you've been out of work for years tell
god you're suffering
tell god you're under persecution on the
job tell
god you've been outcast or cast out by
your family members
tell god you're all alone and desperate
for social support
tell god what's going on because god is
asking you
as jesus asked that man and as jesus
asked blind bartimaeus how
are you doing you can tell god i'm doing
badly
and i need help and as surely as that
man in
mark 9 told jesus if thou can't do
anything
have compassion on us and help us you
say to god
if you are god and say it respectfully
have compassion
on me in my circumstances and help me
and as i close by faith
listen to god saying to you how
are you doing tell him not well
i need help and you will hear him say
come unto me you individually
you're laboring you're heavy laden and i
the create of heaven and earth for whom
nothing is impossible
will give you rest may the lord bless
you
as you give him your life that he may
make of your life
a bright jewel